voy a definir una función s que depende
de nuestra variable n como la suma la
suma de todos de todos los números
enteros positivos de todos los enteros
positivos hasta n ok
quizás también en algún libro lo puedas
buscar como la suma de todos los
naturales hasta n muy bien es lo mismo
entonces esta definición de lo que es la
suma pues inmediatamente me me arroja
valores para cada número natural o
entero positivo que yo le ponga por
ejemplo qué tal que quiero calcular esta
función en 3 eso me dice que voy a tomar
todos los enteros positivos hasta 3
entonces es uno más 2 + 3 esto es 6
verdad uno más dos son tres tres más
tres son seis por ejemplo quién sería
ese de 4 s de 4 es uno más dos más tres
que ahí son seis más cuatro y esto es 10
entonces esto es una función que a cada
número
la asocia otro número natural entonces
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es es
demostrar que aunque hay muchas formas
de demostrar esto que voy a decir lo que
voy a demostrar es que sn
es decir puedo yo encontrar una fórmula
que depende de n para esta para esta
expresión y de hecho es n por n 1 sobre
2 muy bien entonces como es que lo voy a
hacer pues esto va a ser una
demostración por inducción una
demostración por inducción y eso es una
una cosa fantástica puede es una forma
filosófica y muy interesante de
demostrar algunas afirmaciones
matemáticas lo primero que tengo que
hacer es demostrar un caso base caso
base aunque hay que que en realidad aquí
para nuestro problema pues nuestro caso
o nuestro caso base va a ser 1 ok vamos
a demostrar que nuestra fórmula es
cierta vamos a demostrar
que la fórmula es cierta para para n
igual a 1 es decir si yo tengo la suma
de todos los enteros positivos hasta 1
quiero ver que la fórmula se cumple
luego ya que tenemos un caso base voy a
cuando ya voy a hacer el paso inductivo
el paso inductivo y esto el paso
inductivo es fundamental es es lo que le
da razón de ser a todo esto el paso
inductivo consiste en suponer suponer
que la formulita es cierta para algún
número natural digamos para para algún k
ok digamos que que esta fórmula de aquí
está que voy a enmarcar esta de aquí es
cierta para algún número ok entonces lo
que voy a tratar de demostrar en el paso
inductivo es que la formulita va a ser
cierta para el siguiente número natural
es decir vamos a demostrar que si se
vale para un número
entonces se vale para el siguiente
número entonces qué es lo que estamos
haciendo
tenemos digamos aquí el 1 el 2 el 3 el 4
el 5 o el 6 de así ok entonces nosotros
vamos a demostrar el caso base vamos a
demostrar que se vale para uno y después
vamos a demostrar bueno
el paso inductivo te dice bueno suponte
que se vale para algún número en
particular entonces se tiene que valer
para el siguiente pero nosotros ya
demostramos el caso base entonces se
tiene que valer para el siguiente pero
como se vale para dos entonces se va a
tener que valer para tres y si se vale
para tres se va a tener que valer para
cuatro y así sucesivamente nos podemos
seguir y demostrar entonces que se vale
para todos los números naturales ok
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
demostrar el caso base que esta
formulita es cierta para cuando en es
igual a 1 después vamos a suponer que la
fórmula se va se vale para cierto número
acá y vamos a demostrar entonces que la
fórmula se vale para el siguiente número
entonces empecemos con el paso inductivo
ese uno por definición es la suma de
todos los enteros positivos hasta uno y
pues no hay otro número entero positivo
más allá que el uno verdad entonces esto
es sumar todos los enteros positivos
hasta uno pues es uno ahora bien que nos
dice la fórmula si yo sustituyó uno por
uno más uno que entre dos esto es igual
a uno por dos sobre dos que es dos entre
dos y esto es igual a uno entonces la
formulita se vale para cuando me tomo n
igual a uno ok y realmente el caso base
aquí me está diciendo que se va que va a
ser cierto a partir de 1 en adelante por
ejemplo a lo mejor para otro problema en
particular puede ser 55 o algún número
que tú quieras muy bien en este caso se
vale a partir de 1 entonces ahora
vámonos al paso inductivo vámonos al
paso inductivo suponemos cierto
suponemos
si suponemos cierto para algún número
que cierto para acá esto es que nuestra
nuestra nuestra suma de todos los
enteros positivos hasta acá vale lo que
nos dice la fórmula cada por acá más uno
entre dos muy bien entonces lo que yo
quiero hacer ahora es calcular quién es
la fórmula para el siguiente muy bien
entonces la fórmula para el siguiente
dijimos que es uno más dos más tres y
así sumamos todos sumamos acá y hasta
acá más uno que esté en un solo número
entonces ya que tenemos esto lo que
podemos hacer es agrupar de esta forma
agrupamos los primeros cannes y te das
cuenta los primeros acá es justamente la
suma de los primeros k enteros verdad
positivos entonces esto es justo la
formulita de aquí tenemos la la suma de
los primeros k enteros positivos me dice
que vale cada por acá más 1 / 2
esto es acá porque uno sobre dos y luego
le sumamos esta otra parte ahora sumamos
acá más uno que es esto bueno saquemos
un denominador común
esto será 2 2 entre 2 es uno por acá
porque amazon está por acá más uno muy
bien simplemente esto es exactamente
esto de aquí y ahora le sumamos dos
veces acá más uno si si te fijas sólo en
esta parte sólo en esta parte de aquí
tenemos dos veces camas 1 / 2 pues
simplemente escamas o lo que es lo que
teníamos aquí ok entonces ahí es desde
ahí ya lo tenemos y ahora lo que podemos
hacer es factorizar camas o no acá
arriba podemos factorizar camas o no
en verde factorizar mosca más uno en el
numerador y ahora eso multiplica a quien
esto multiplica acá
+ 2 verdad este 22 simplemente lo que
hice fue factorizar y todo esto va
dividido entre 2 entonces si te das
cuenta esto es lo mismo que acá más 1 x
por acá más uno más uno sobre dos y qué
es lo que nos diría la fórmula para acá
más una verdad aquí debería ir camas uno
aquí acá más uno más uno sobre dos
entonces lo que acabamos de demostrar es
que si se vale para cierto número acá
entonces también se vale para el
siguiente verdad es decir aquí aquí
esta fórmula se vale para acá entonces
se vale para cada mazón y como además
demostramos nuestra base es decir para n
igual a 1 entonces aquí ya digamos
demostramos este entonces cómo se vale
si se vale para cierto número se vale
para el siguiente como se vale para uno
entonces se vale para dos pero ahora se
vale para dos y como se vale para el
siguiente entonces se vale para tres y
así sucesivamente verdad ahora sólo lo
que hicimos fue esto la idea básica de
la inducción es tener un caso base
demostrar que se vale lo que uno quiera
demostrar verdad en este caso sería
nuestra fórmula
pues el paso inductivo consiste en
suponer que se vale para cierto número
acá y demostrar que se vale para el
siguiente ok entonces de esta forma
nosotros estamos demostrando que la
formulita es cierta para todos los
números naturales y puedes pensar que la
inducción es como como las piezas de
dominó cuando las acomodas y dejas caer
una como que como que funciona en
cascada verdad funciona para uno y
después empieza a funcionar para todos
los siguientes y podemos seguir y seguir
y seguir de esta forma por siempre esa
es la idea de la inducción así que
tenemos que esta fórmula es cierta para
todos los enteros positivos